how did you choose the seniors to be in
the dock because you just have just the
most lovable like oh I want to take them
home and have them be my grandparents
you know like how did you choose them
i'm sure there's probably some that you
couldn't use for whatever reason maybe
they were still great but it just didn't
fit into the realm of the story so what
was the selection process like well we
started off filming was a huge group of
senior citizens and we kind of just went
door-to-door in the retirement residence
giving them lessons and filming and you
slowly we just started narrowing down
based on the people that were most into
it the ones that were picking it up
quickly and the ones that were
interesting to watch on camera the
people that you know liked being on
camera and we're kind of warm towards us
one the cameras there some people just
didn't like being from the camera so
that helped doesn't narrow them out and
we were just lucky to find some really
funny charismatic senior citizens and
there were some that didn't make the
final cut who you know we're in an edit
even a year ago that I just had to cut a
few months ago just because there wasn't
enough time but yeah we were just really
lucky with the people that we found yeah
it's an excellent mix and I'll always
excuse me I like to how they were very
open about some of their family
situations and not holding back
especially to being from a generation
that's probably not as open about things
I thought that they shared some
interesting things yeah I found
especially with the men I mean to see
men of that age kind of open up and be
even a little bit emotional on camera is
not something that you're used to seeing
but you know we have these 90 year old
men who talked about their family with
such pride and got a little teary-eyed
when they got you know Facebook message
things like that I thought were really
heartwarming
you